well i got a debate club i was just
thinking of and brenda you have a kid so
you probably
i don't know probably have an opinion on
this more than us but what about that
hee haw see-saw versus that
swing set that swinging baby which one
yeah i love a nice swing set the problem
with that seesaw it's all about
injuries these days so as a parent you
always gotta you always kind of gotta
you know you're stressed out depending
on the injury those seesaws you don't
listen there ain't many seesaws in la
man i i think they got rid of them
yeah there's a lot of bridges see so
yeah there's virtual ones here
where you're you and your kid the kids
stand like 10 feet apart and imagine
that they're on a seesaw
it's a bombing now swings are still
pretty lit though there's swings
everywhere
yeah and there's like um yes
there's like a closet on the a lot of
the playgrounds there's a closet on it
and the kid can practice coming out of
the closet out here in los angeles
yeah they actually encouraged i feel the
see-saw is like a bully like people can
use it to bully have you ever seen that
in cartoons yeah
see-saw up and down on somebody yeah on
their head they would do that a lot yeah
a lot of times
they would um yeah kid was a little too
aggressive somebody really pounce it up
get you
up there and threaten you [ __ ] yeah make
you throw your lunch money down they
used to do that sometimes to get off of
there
remember the one not the merry-go-round
but it's like that was like the
the thing and someone would run and spin
it around mirrors metal
oh yeah [ __ ] yeah that shit's all
dangerous people always die out there
but
you gotta thin the herd some people
can't handle the heat now i was on a
swing set the other day i took a date to
a uh
like a park and then we got on the
swings man
wow what are you 14 do you did you start
sweating when you held her hand
was it midnight was it park hours or it
was park i was just daytime hours
did you guys share a caprice that's a
cute idea
i like it we had a thank you nick it was
a nice idea
nick slept in a park last night he's
okay with this
nick how big are those swings you have
to like maybe put them together lay down
them like a hammock
i'm sick of this anti-homeless
architecture they're putting everywhere
it's hard to get a good night's rest
yeah so yeah we had a nice time man
the scary part was when you get so fast
on that swing you get that feeling in
your stomach when you go back
like a roller coaster and if you start
going too high so it's going to chin
it gets scared oh yeah you're trying to
go all the way around yeah when you're a
kid you're trying to go all the way it
never happened never happened for me
i liked that i was the kid that would
wait till it was real high
jump off oh yeah like mission impossible
i was that kid that kid was always in
the high ankle sprain
yeah you had a few ankles no i used to
do that too yeah i was too heavy to be
doing that but you would get
so high you're straight up at the skies
thought she was gonna be in like a space
or something
that was fun you break your arm you go
from a swing to a swing oh yeah
very popular man yeah i vote swing set
man i'm swing set now on your date did
you get behind your girl and pusher
um no i didn't i thought about it still
it's too high
slow down i thought about it and then if
you really want to get into it you push
her and you run
underneath so she really flies oh that's
crazy brenda oh yeah that's crazy you
got to be careful
make sure you clear it cause they'll
come back on you yeah if you don't
run out far enough well well yeah i
didn't get into all that you guys are
freaking
pretty romantic i said okay
[Music]
is